voters in the united kingdom head to the
polls for a general snap election that
will decide the fate of brexit the
long-delayed British withdrawal from the
European Union to understand the stakes
of the election which will likely result
in the Conservative Party's Boris
Johnson or Labour's Jeremy Corbyn
becoming Prime Minister reason sat down
with Daniel Hannan a conservative member
of the European Union's Parliament and
one of the leading architects of brexit
in a wide-ranging conversation Hannon
explains why British libertarians voted
overwhelmingly in favour of exit the
urgency of honouring the results of the
2016 referendum in which 52 percent of
voters called for leave and why he
believes a Corbin victory will set the
UK on the path to Venezuelan style neo
socialism Daniel Hannan thanks for
talking to us for always a great
pleasure to be with you so we've got a
snap election coming up that will
determine who controls Parliament
possibly the future of brexit this is
just a few days away
give me the libertarian defense for
brexit free trade abroad and
decentralization of power at home most
UK libertarians I would say 90 to 95
percent voted Lee now that is not to say
that the majority of the 17 point four
million leave voters were libertarians
because we are a quite small chunk of
the population in the UK as here as as
everywhere but I think the view was that
the European Union had become
self-serving remote cut off from the
people it purported to speak for and
therefore like all governments in that
situation bloated and expensive so why
has brexit proved impossible to
implement so far what's taking so simply
that there was a majority in the House
of Commons determined to thwart it since
the 2017 elections of the the referendum
happened in June 2016 12 months later
there was a general election Theresa May
lost her parliamentary majority so from
that moment there was a majority of MPs
who were not going to let breaks it
happen in most cases they didn't have
the courage openly to vote just to
cancel the whole thing and then go back
and face their constituents so they
voted against every conceivable form
that breaks it might have practically
taken they created this gridlock this
complete mess and then they pointed at
the messin said all look this is all
terrible you know maybe we should drop
the whole idea that was that that was a
tactic but they you know people are not
that dim everyone could see perfectly
well what was going on and so eventually
there had to be a dissolution it was it
was clear to the country the Parliament
was simply blocking brexit and the issue
that is going to be decided is it's one
week away as we record this interview
will be whether we get a government that
has the majority to deliver and it is I
mean it is kind of stunning I know
people who are Briggs that people are
leave people whether on the right or the
left
you had a referendum where if my read a
research is correct more people voted in
favor of leaving the EU than have ever
voted for anything right in English more
than ever before and everyone in advance
of that referendum especially the
remainders said this is it this is a
once-in-a-lifetime vote there's because
they were confident that they would
correct yeah right and here we are I
mean I I have a little boy who is
three-and-a-half years old he has spent
his entire life in a country that has
voted to leave the European Union but is
not in fact left the European Union so
this is this is now way beyond brexit
this is about the legitimacy and
authority of our political institutions
if despite all the promises they made if
MPs can't deliver on something as
central as this why on earth should
people believe anything that any
politician tells them and that that's
what's now at stake how is the American
media gotten the reasons behind brexit
wrong it really extraordinarily so I
mean I I was expecting a certain
misunderstanding or kind of
results-driven analysis from some of the
complemental European media I was
stunned by the extent to which the
Washington Post particularly the New
York Times have invented this kind of
complete fantasy saying things that no
remain newspaper in Britain would dare
get away with you know that the whole
vote was angry nostalgic nativist
anti-immigrant it was a kind of form of
British trumpism but worse and in
parallel this you know the casual reader
of those titles would be forgiven for
thinking
Britain is in an economic crisis that
we've all changed our minds that there's
a great sense of regret that we're
scrambling for foreign passport in fact
we've boomed we've we've outgrown the
eurozone we've got record employment
figures we've got a record stock
exchange we've had more foreign
investment than any country in the world
except China and the the predictions
that were made by the Romanians have
turned out to be utterly utterly wrong
and yet this hasn't led to any modesty
any going back and questioning of
principles they've just stuck with their
line of you know you're a bunch of
xenophobes and all this Arthur Arthur
profound ways in which the EU and you
know this is slowly separate from the
question of brexit but where the EU is a
kind of triumph of liberal aspiration so
to create a free trade zone and and a
free movement zone within most of Europe
continent that was killing it drag each
other you know 75 years ago well there
is something called the European free
trade association which is exactly that
which a number of whose members deserted
and joined the European Union including
Britain but the remaining members Norway
Iceland Switzerland and Liechtenstein
are the richest and most successful and
most contented countries in Europe
because they have gone for free trade
for a common market but not a common
government they've they've gone for that
model of cooperation and indeed free
movement of people as part of free trade
or a free movement of workers it doesn't
carry all the the rights to benefits and
so on but without political union if
that had been on the menu there would be
no referendum in Britain there'd be no
argument in Britain why would anyone
have been against that the trouble was
that the European Union aspired to
become a state and so they you mentioned
that brexit and the election of Donald
Trump get linked all the time and and
people were lost highly just because of
the coincidences of time right but they
were both surprising why is it wrong or
are they are they analogous events or
are they really completely independent
well I think the last time I spoke to
you they were they were very recent we
spoke in in late 2016 and or the last
time I spoke to you on camera I should
say and I remember saying then look that
there are some really important
differences for example a big part of
trumps campaign as far as I understand
we
that you know he didn't want free trade
it was particularly didn't want free
trade with China they were manipulating
currencies and all this whereas a very
big part of the leave campaign which we
had in all our literature was that we do
want free trade including with China you
know and we're not getting it because
the EU is protectionist and we can now
be a much more global country our our
slogan one of our slogans was global
Britain it's a we we have this idea that
outside the European Union we can be a
much more open economy and much more
competitive economy and not least we can
have successful trade deals with friends
and allies including in the US now
et is true that if you are arguing
against a long-established dispensation
you're going to be using some parallel
arguments about the failure of existing
ellipse and that that's inevitable
whether you're arguing for Scottish
independence or brexit or Donald Trump
order so though we're therefore of
course some parallels and similarities
in terms of the the presentation but I
think the if the if the Pro leave
campaign had been the backward looking
protectionist anti-immigrant movement
that remain as painted as being we
wouldn't have got close to fifty percent
you have spoken about the rise of what
you called Bannon ISM and Bernie ISM so
in Steve Bannon on the one hand the
former adviser to Trump who's a
unabashed nationalist nativist populist
Bernie Sanders a populist on the
progressive left what do you mean by
that phrase and what are they fueled by
the same anxieties or I mean I think you
know what what the economic nationalists
and the Socialists have in common is if
you like the elevation of the collective
over the individual and the the
readiness to deploy state power for our
own good as they would see it I'm struck
and I'm not sure which man will be more
horrified by this parallel but I'm
struck by the similarities in tone in
many ways between Jeremy Corbyn and
Donald Trump both in terms of what they
say about you know building things in
our own country and protecting the
economy and standing up for workers and
so on but also
in their in their approach to
campaigning the the famous observation
that the American voters took Trump
seriously but not literally Corbin is
banking on something very similar you
know he will come out with extraordinary
ridiculous vast exaggerated figures in
not in the expectation that any was
actually going to believe it but in the
expectation that he's kind of making a
point that will resonate there you know
what's a specifically desert well I mean
that he's gonna be increasing money for
everybody he's gonna be giving more to
students to pensioners to benefits
claimants to government workers and all
over this is gonna be paid for by a
small tax on the top 5% now nobody
actually believes that I mean even even
the Labour Party spokesman when they're
sort of giving the party line you can
tell they don't really do you think no
it's more that he's trying to make the
point that we're on the side of the
little guy by making a ridiculous penny
in much to say that when I say Trump II
in its in its form it's a little bit
like you know when Trump said crime is
spiraling and we've got all these
violent I mean that was not literally
true crime was falling at the time he
said that but he was making the point
that I take this issue more seriously
than these other issues right when he
said were being flooded with immigrants
from Mexico and we've got to build this
well I mean 2015 was the first year that
saw more Mexicans crossing South the
north but again he was making the point
that I at least I'm gonna take this
issue seriously and I think Corbin has
learned from that I and I don't know
whether they're it's kind of fluke or
tactical genius or some kind of idiots
have an idiot 7th wave but somehow in
the modern age because you've got this
multiplicity of media because you've got
so many if you like alternative versions
of the facts out there it's much easier
whether you're a trump II or a korbinite
to to believe your version of facts to
to find some statistic somewhere that
will sustain the conclusion that you
began with let's talk about the
resurgence of interest in socialism in
the UK and in the u.s. how is socialism
being defined
in the current moment especially by
younger people and what do you think
explains its yeah I'm popular well that
the one thing that socialists will never
do is give an example of a successful
socialist state
they can't right I mean it because it
ends the same way every time in Angola
in Benin in Czechoslovakia here if you
go all the way down the alphabet right
and and when I say it ends the same way
every time I don't just mean it ends in
poverty I mean it ends in labor camps
and Galax and one party control so what
people say is yeah but I'm not talking
about you know North Korean or Russian
or Cuban or Venezuelan so I'm talking
about this kind of abstract socialism
that no one has yet tried and you're
therefore I mean of course you can win
that high if you're if you're judging
socialism only as a textbook theory that
you're judging capitalism by it's
necessarily imperfect real-world
outcomes and of course you can win that
argument right the trouble is because a
lot of young people have no memory of
the real-world failures of actual
socialism they can only judge it as an
abstract proposition rather than as an
empirical reality and so all of the old
fallacies come back and this I think is
the the reason why organizations like
reason and the Liberty movement more
widely and never going to go out of
business
every generation like a moth to a flame
is going to be drawn back to the
apparent verities the apparent you know
apparently common sensical assertions of
socialism you know well I have two
factories producing exactly the same
thing when the government can just
reallocate one of them to a more
socially productive end you know but I
allow the economy just to arrange itself
higgledy-piggledy when with a little bit
of central direction you could eliminate
inefficiencies you know why allow only
the profit motive to decide how the
economy should be run when when we have
all this brain power that we could do
all of those things sound completely
reasonable right they they all if you
like go with the grain of human nature
they chime with our in heritage
intuitions and instincts that we
observed is very well as the species for
a million years it's just that they are
all utter [ __ ] and whenever they've
been tried it's ended up in poverty and
tyranny do you think part of the
response to and I'm thinking of the
coinage of or the phrase fanon ISM and
Bernie ISM yeah which I think gets at
something profound as different as they
might be in their particulars both
Bannon and Bernie say well you know
contemporary capitalism sure you you
have cheap cell phones and a lot of TV
yeah you know cheap TVs and you could
play computer games but you don't have
any real meaning it's extraordinary
isn't it and this is well this except
it's not extraordinary it's a very
natural thing in every single generation
has this alienation let's call it that
this sense that there's something
missing to become solar smih T realistic
and so there was a one of those kind of
Salafi nutters in the Middle East who
came up with a fantastic phrase when he
said we want your TV sets we just don't
want the TV programs that come with them
and he Pro he couldn't see that that's a
package that the society that gives you
the programs he didn't like is also the
one that develops the technology right
and and that you don't get to pick and
choose those things I mean here's what I
think it all is you know like I say we
evolved in a very different environment
we evolved in kin groups we have a
genetic predisposition to egalitarianism
and to to kin group solidarity and to a
certain coercion that's that's how you
how you survive as a hunter-gatherer
we've been transplanted as if to a like
like a colony on another planet you know
in a completely different environment so
this is the world of skyscrapers and
dependence on strangers that you can't
see for things that you probably would
hire called the extended order correct
and that is that feels wrong to us every
day because on a genetic intuitive level
it is wrong it's not all we evolved for
and so in every generation you've had
people making the Bannon Sanders
argument right something has gone wrong
what if everyone is so rich why don't I
feel happier why haven't we lost the
important things what about fan
and friends and faith and all the things
that matter more than markets and and
that that that's protest that that
revolution against modernity can take
the lots of different forms it can take
the form of revolutionary socialism it
can take the form of fascism it could
take the form of Romanticism I mean
that's basically the romantic was that
you know that the whole country
enlightenment was about that it could
take the form of you know the the the
the camera and Sartre and those other
idiot existentialist but it's the same
basic thing I probably going back to
Rousseau I think he's probably the first
guy to say there is something wrong with
the way I'm feeling about and he he
lived that age you know I mean you see
kind of existential angst as a luxury
good it you know what it all it it is
the it is the anguished cry of our inner
caveman who just cannot believe or
accept that the world is as good as it
is and that's why you and I and the rest
of us who get the the miracle of market
capitalism are never gonna be out of
work because we have to keep explaining
this all over again to people who take
prosperity for granted that's you know
very comforting we we are going to you
are going to do speaking at a recent
conference in Guatemala that's held next
February you're gonna be talking about
socialism we are in Guatemala you were
born and raised in Peru and you're going
to be talking about Venezuela a lot does
the Venezuela example you know is that
what we need to focus on more to show
where this stuff ends up or is that too
far afield from you know saying you know
if Jeremy Corbyn is elected in the UK
you blink your eyes and you're gonna be
no no I I don't think that's a figure of
speech
when I was growing up in Peru Venezuela
was the country that people emigrated to
the idea that it couldn't happen here
which is a dangerously complacent and
recurrent theme in both British and
American politics I just don't think
he's borne out what is the nature of the
failure in Venezuela that led to a rapid
decline from you know the early I I
don't know when you want to take the the
beginning of the end was it in the
late 70s when industries were
nationalized when it was Chavez was
pardoned and let out of prison was it
when he won his second or what I mean
you know it's difficult onto that
question briefly I'd make it let me make
a general point about Latin America that
is sometimes missed at the end of the
Cold War was as much a liberation for
much of Latin America as it was for
Eastern Europe that that the pressure
that had led to various kind of
dictatorial regimes backed by one side
or the other disappeared and there was a
mass democratization in the late 80s and
early nineties across the continent the
first wave of non socialist governments
royally screwed things up
they were Pro business rather than Pro
market they opened the door to
corruption and immobile ISM and
oligarchy and these were were these are
countries where there are inequalities
of wealth where there are racial
disparities and these people are often
spoke too language of laissez-faire
economic government you know kind of
national conservative with the exception
of Alvaro Uribe in Colombia he was the
the one who came closest to a genuine
market conservatism there was a moment
run about 2004 when when or Ebay in
South America was the only leader who
was not on the populist left because
there was a backlash understandably and
these various governments of the
revolutionary left also failed failed
miserably failed worse than they throw
Washington governments in the 90s and
particularly failed for the people that
they had purported to speak for and
we've now I think reached the end of
that phase and so in it went back to
some something a little bit more like
normal politics but in Venezuela it went
further than in other places because the
high oil price shielded Chavez from the
catastrophic costs of his own policies
so things that would have destroyed
another country much more quickly
you know the centralization of the means
of distribution the imposition of state
monopolies import substitution all that
you know take every box that how to make
a country poor
the effects of that were for a long time
deferred because of these massive
inflows from oil which allowed him not
only to buy support at home but also to
buy it abroad to sponsor and Bolivarian
revolution Zell swear and it was only
when that spike in oil came to an end
that the consequences of Chevys more
caught up with him and we can see it the
worst refugee crisis in the Western
Hemisphere
I mean case it got the country that was
richer than a lot of Europe in living
memory and where there are now deaths
through malnutrition I mean it is
absolutely stunning and a horrible
reminder of how quickly things can go
wrong you have described Miami Florida
as the greatest Latin American city in
the world no what do you mean by that
everybody what is the larger less the
great creation of Fidel Castro was the
mercantile and cultural center that is
Miami you know and what I would say from
that is well one of the interesting
questions is why did why did Latin
American not develop in the way that
english-speaking America did most
Central and South American countries
became independent kind of you know in
the 1820s most of them copied versions
of your constitution but they didn't
import the constitutional stability that
North Americans as we Latinos so take
for granted they've had with a few
exceptions but in many cases they've had
a series of revolutions and coos and
dictatorships despite on paper having
similar systems why is that is it a
cultural thing is it you know some some
property in the soil or the gene pool I
always think culture is it is it kind of
cop out on these occasions culture is
not some disembodied numinous entity
that kind of floats alongside a country
we need is a product of the institutions
of that country
and I think the real difference is that
there was an absolute emphasis first of
all on property rights in the US that
had come from England in a way that the
equivalent had not happened in Iberian
America second that there was a
decentralized form of Gotham
in in North America there was the
tradition right from the beginning of
electing your own mayors and sheriffs
and so on in a way that was was
unthinkable under the Spanish monarchy
and so although the paper rights were
the same the underpinning institutions
the wider cultural institutions were not
but the the point of Miami is it shows
it you know you take you take people
from any of those countries and you you
put them in a place where property is
secure and where you can reasonably
invest and expect your return and they
will behave just like any other
Americans I mean that there is no lack
of entrepreneurial spirit in Latin
America so it's the system rather than
the end of that courage which is a
weirdly anti libertarian anti
individualist thing to say well you know
put it like this if you you know if you
swapped at birth a baby from Wisconsin
with one from you know Quito it's you
wouldn't suddenly see some magical
change in in their lives in the new but
they would they would operate within the
context of the institutions and
structures of their of their new country
but I mean the good news is that that
means it can be reformed you know the
trouble is that reform is always against
the interests of the established elite
and that's true
whether we're talking about oligarchs in
South America who are experts in
rent-seeking who have learned how to
loot the state through political
connections or at a different level
whether it's the kind of pro EU elites
in a country like mine who have learned
how to make a handy living out of the
system and don't want any change right
isn't it's not that the country as a
whole is gonna be worse off but their
own position will be threatened by any
change specifically in Latin America how
much you know one of the arguments of
why is Latin America so poor it's
because the United States did things
such as you know helped overthrow
democratically elected governments and
in a wide variety of countries we closed
our eyes you know while people were
being thrown out of helicopters there's
also an argument that at least during
the Cold War that the Soviet
we're doing something in the same yeah
how how important is that it's not I
mean it is an amazing kind of solecism
all human beings put themselves at the
center of the universe and we do that
politically when we say whatever has
happened in the other side of the world
is somehow our responsibility and in
fact the way you phrase the question
which i think is very accurate is also
very telling that you know you overthrew
governments and you turned a blind eye
so simultaneously America is wrong when
it intervenes and when it doesn't
intervene right because everything is
always about us you know what it isn't
the reason that you know Mexico is in a
mess now is because Mexico has a crappy
government which is making bad decisions
and having Cuba's paradigmatic example
there's no question the United States
wanted regime change there they failed
in that Castro though and his policies
having this as a country they they
couldn't trade with the US but take a
trade with everyone else so I mean it
may be the case that the blockade kept
Castro in power longer because it gave
him the Arctic man to lose you know but
and it's also true the United States and
you don't have to go along with this our
United States citizen and a good
libertarian I mean we did horrible
things in Latin America look but but but
we should guard against this peculiar
self-centeredness that borders almost on
kind of mass racism of treating other
countries as and people in other
countries as though they lacked
all-agency as though anything they do is
entirely up to us and they are a kind of
inert mass who only ever respond to US
policy right so the classic example of
this is that Venezuela failed because of
US sanctions these miraculous
time-traveling US sanctions that were
imposed in 2017 and was so powerful that
they went back and caused a crisis from
2013 or indeed earlier right and by the
way these sanctions were a tiny targeted
you know as a microsurgery kind of
sanction against some of the socialist
aliefs who've been looting the place but
if you are determined enough in a kind
of corbin way to see everything in the
world as the fault of america and to
some extent the fault of Britain in
Israel
then you'll be able to find that you'll
be able to join the dots however
tenuously and sustain your prejudice so
the election is coming up you obviously
you want Boris Johnson and the
Conservatives to win is that going to
happen and if it does happen what are
they gonna do I can't tell you whether
it's gonna happen because this is not a
Venezuelan election or a Russian
election or Chinese election in America
we eyes right where we are you know one
of the one of the greater the last free
place on earth with good election yeah
we still got it we still got properly
yeah properly uncertain elections well
but Johnson or the Conservatives are up
or something like nine percent yeah oh
are they gonna win but not enough for I
was gonna say I think if we if we don't
win a plurality of the vote I will be
very very surprised but vote for boring
complicated reasons that we're fighting
on a rather outdated electoral map which
means that you need more votes to elect
a conservative MPs and to elect a Labour
MP so we if we both get exactly the same
vote Labour wins plus we need to get an
absolute majority to form a government
because the Scottish Nationals and so on
have said that they will not support us
so if we're one short that results at
least in the short term in in a Corbin
Premiership and that's why I can't say
for sure that the because we're ahead in
the polls are you worried at all about
what the Conservative Party though is
offering in England or in Britain the
party has promised to reduce immigration
overall so that you know which again I
understand your argument in the
libertarian or liberal argument to get
out of brexit but there were a lot of
people who seem to be anti-immigrant
it's talking about throwing billions of
new pounds at national health is the
Conservative Party really the party of
limited government yeah limited
government definitely is it the kind of
libertarian party that you and I would
draw up from first principles no and it
never will be and nor will any other
party right I mean or rather any party
that is like the Liberty everybody here
is
be limited to kind of 3% in any election
so Boris is a perfect leader human
without any problems any shortcomings he
is human and therefore he is not perfect
and his conservatism is is much more
Biddle of the road on economics but I'd
make two points first of all this is an
emergency
so against a and unapologetically
Marxist leader who backed the other side
during the Cold War I mean that's how
serious it is in that situation every
libertarian every conservative every
Christian Democrat every moderate
centrist indeed every social democrat
should rally behind the guy who's gonna
solve the Marxist turn second i-i've
known Boris for a long time he is one of
the cleverest people I've ever come
across may be the cleverest I've worked
with and he gets that money doesn't grow
on trees he understands that free
enterprise is necessary to him to growth
and prosperity and he gets that in a
democracy you can considerably tilt the
balance back towards the private sector
without needing to make any cuts indeed
while making increases targeted
increases in public spending provided
that you get the overall monetary and
fiscal framework right so that you're
allowing the private sector to grow
faster than the public sector this is
actually what Margaret Thatcher did it
every year that she was in in office
contrary to almost universal belief
public spending slightly grew but the
private sector grew a lot faster you've
got kids you mentioned your three and a
half year old son are you confident that
they'll live in a freer fairer you know
richer better world than well now richer
and better I think almost and anyone
who'd made that prediction at any time
in the last three hundred years would
have been laughs that one would have
been right you know I don't expect I
mean that you know Jeremy Corbyn is
trying to mandate a four-day week with
state coercion I suspect my kids will be
working far shorter hours living far
better that we can
just as we are compared to our
grandparents you know the thing that
worries me because I don't want to be
completely I don't want to just want to
do the whole sort of you know norburg
Ridley pinker everything is getting
better forever and ever I meant there is
one thing that really worries me and it
is the the pre enlightenment thinking
that is creeping in to not just higher
education but but secondary education as
well now you know saying earlier
socialism chimes with with our kind of
Paleolithic instincts right we are we're
not a libertarian the species by by
nature we've had to learn that we've had
to learn it empirically we've had to see
that it works better than we've had to
teach it and that lovely line that
Hannah Arendt once used that in every
generation of the West is invaded by
barbarians we call them children in
other words you and I come into the
world pretty much with the same
equipment that we would had on fifty
thousand years ago the reason that we
live in compliment rather than the way
we did fifty thousand years ago is
because of learned institutions that are
transmitted and for a long time that was
the primary function of education it was
to teach people that some of the rules
of thumb and heuristics that they were
born with were no longer apt in the
modern world and in particular to teach
them the value of personal
responsibility right so that I would say
the real essence of modernity the basis
of the post enlightenment society is the
move away from caste and status and
birth and and tradition towards the idea
that you and I can make a contract and
there's no one else's business that like
I said we're not born thinking that
that's logical we have to be taught why
that works and what really alarms me
when I now look at universities and high
schools is that not only are we not
teaching that we are increasingly
teaching the opposite instead of the the
basically counter cyclical idea that you
know you're not defined by ancestry and
physiognomy that you're defined by you
and the choices you make and the actions
that you take we're actually teaching
Pro cyclically we're saying no no no in
fact everyone is defined by the fact
that they're black or when
or gay or whatever and I think actually
a lot of conservatives get the tone of
their attack on identity politics wrong
they either laugh at it and you know how
ridiculous political correctness gone
mad all they say you know this is sort
of appalling a president actually is
much more serious I I think we are
reverting to a pre-modern way of
thinking and in a multi-ethnic society
like this one poor indeed like Britain
but once you go down that road of
defining people by ancestry you make a
an open society almost impossible I'm
that sure you know we will leave it
there we have been talking with Daniel
Hannan a member of the European
Parliament at least for a little while
longer and one of the architects of
brexit thank you so much for thank you
Nick for reason I'm Nikolas
[Music]